ow  well pardon the pun but I don't when I  ever egg this things but at the same  time what my concern for was for  Margaret and the disregard the  individual seemed to have for those  others who are in the room and Margaret  was a more elderly woman and she was  bowled over in the exchange and I was  able to help her up to her feet and I've  contacted a since and I understand she's  had some medical attention and she's  fine and that's great and I'm pleased  Margaret is fine I have to say that the  Prime Minister help me get up off the  floor and I was very grateful for his  assistance  I was then bored out here to the first  aide who did a full first aid check and  yes I'm fine